hi everyone I'm Laura Ingram this is
Ingram angle from Minneapolis tonight
still the economy stupid that's the
focus of tonight's angle
Working Class People are a heck of a lot
smarter than politicians and political
Consultants think they are like this man
I ran into in Minneapolis Yesterday by
Dynamics they say is working you know
what as long as you're blind No One
loans you blind because half of them is
like biting they can't think they can't
think at all they can't think straight
at all it's important that that people
of all Races come you need to break up
and look at the issues it's not about
racing on a national level who could
make a difference just to get the
economy going the only person can the
only person can save our Beloved Country
let's be little countries I beloved
president Donald Trump it's important
for us to get him reelected so we can
get this country back up on the right
track as you see all these Democrat
States like Chicago Minneapolis San
Francisco they all got Democrat Mayors
and look what's happening
that guy should have his own show and we
all know what happened to our once great
cities there's no spinning it any honest
person who spent time in urban America
can see the Decay we can see it with our
own eyes just like they can see that
their own standard of living has
declined since Biden took office my
salary has not kept up with inflation so
even though uh I'm working I find that
my money is buying less and less when I
go to the grocery store or gas station
anywhere the Biden Administration came
out saying that by nomics is working for
the middle class what are your thoughts
it's not it's not working for my small
business it's not working for our family
I personally was thinking about
retirement now I'm thinking about how
long can I work
every poll is showing that the economy
is the number one issue for the American
people and Biden gets terrible ratings
on his handling of the economy even in
the CNN polls
so Republicans especially Donald Trump
consistently outpole Democrats on the
issue that Biden's weakest on and this
is something that the White House is so
worried about that they're now winding
Biden up and sending him out to brag
about bionomics now in the process he's
trying to out populist Trump on the
economy which is hilarious like he was
America first first let's see if you
notice the similarities here Joe Biden
shipped millions of your best jobs
overseas hollowed out the black middle
class they decided to send the jobs
overseas where the labor was cheaper
entire towns and communities got
hollowed out after many years of decline
American manufacturing is coming back
bigger and better and stronger than ever
before America manufacturing is back
folks America manufacturing is back the
United States lost 60
000 factories
after China
entered the WTO we know for too long
China's dominate the production of raw
materials needed for critical products
we're in a real race China's ahead of us
first remember Biden has a long history
of pretending that he's someone he's not
right we know that and second of course
he's going to fake a trump-like approach
the economy because Trump's policies
actually work and because Biden's
numbers are in the toilet look the facts
are undeniable here Americans were
making more when Trump was president and
they felt more optimistic about the
future barely any inflation low energy
prices it all meant happier and more
hopeful families
meanwhile the progress that Biden was
out touting today in Maine it's a
fantasy inflation may be declining
slightly but big deal since he's the one
who punished us with inflation in the
first place
and the recent slight improvement in our
GDP certainly wouldn't have been
possible without the red states that are
filled with all those Maga Republicans
Biden thinks are so terrible working as
hard as they have it's because those
governors in those red States rejected
lockdowns and frankly the entire Biden
approach to covid and of course at the
same time they're pushing pro-growth
policies all those policies that Biden
hates
so Biden right now is trying to be both
a globalist and a populist but it
doesn't work
in the past month blinken Carrie and
Yellen all traveled to China not to help
Main Street but to reassure Wall Street
look you can't be a populist and suck up
to the CCP at the same time and Biden's
supposed for made in America today it's
all just talk he already told the EU
that he was going to tweak the made in
America Provisions that would hurt their
Imports that he inserted in that
so-called inflation reduction act so
those are out the window
in the real world facts are facts and
despite Democrat spins on the economy
look Reality Bites here
courtesy of Biden's destructive domestic
and foreign policy gasoline is now at an
eight-month high as Russia Now is
working with OPEC to drive down Supply
and all of us that go to the grocery
store know that food costs are still way
up they're up a year ago bread frozen
vegetables pet food all of it it's a
joke and it's all on Biden's shoulders
and who can't help but notice the spike
and homelessness all across America it's
heartbreaking and it's infuriating and
it should not be happening in the United
States of America but sadly that's what
you get more of with a bad economy and
an open border
yet the insulated Elites in the media
there's still phleonics that Joe and
Kamala aren't getting economic credit
the economy seems to be doing fairly
well why is it that so many people are
walking around in this country today
Satan it's terrible it takes a long time
for people to get over uh economic
shocks and bad news when they see a lot
of inflation they assume it's bad for
them they kept hearing reports for the
last year and a half that we are headed
into a recession that that kind of fear
plus I think the strut the stress from
covid that's really held Biden's economy
numbers down
yeah people are down on the economy
because they're hearing reports that
we're going into recession
really
again they think you're that stupid
now we all know that Americans who are
well off they can absorb the obscene
increases in food travel and energy
costs
but Biden's policies we know caused all
this but for the vast majority it's all
just more hardship and for those who are
living paycheck to paycheck it's all
they think about
and people wonder gosh why does Trump
have such a hold on GOP voters why does
he have such a loyal following
well first because he has a record of
delivering a strong economy and second
because for the most part he's the only
candidate really focusing on the economy
so many young people here are being
utterly extinguished
in the Biden economy one-third of gen Z
and millennials have no savings accounts
and no saving whatsoever they have
nothing he's absolutely right about that
and he's laid out a clear economic
agenda when I'm back in the white house
I will immediately unleash energy
production slash regulations like I did
just three years ago and repeal Biden's
tax hikes to get inflation down as fast
as possible and it will go quickly so
that interest rates can get back under
control I built the greatest economy in
the history of the world and now we will
have to do it again
check out the headline that I found
today when I was writing the angle from
2018. Trump has set economic growth on
fire here's how he did it
well during his time in office the
economy had achieved Feats most experts
thought impossible GDP growing at three
percent plus rate the unemployment rate
near a 50-year low meanwhile the stock
market has jumped 27 percent they wrote
amid a surge in corporate profits
yeah that's where we were
it took a china-generated pandemic to
stop the juggernaut
now the amazing thing is that everyone
did better than blue collar workers Wall
Street Silicon Valley everyone
but if the Republicans leave this Lane
this economic Lane open for Biden's
message on the economy that somehow
things are all getting better and he's
gets all the credit if they forget to
remind everyone that real wages are down
three percent from February 2021 and if
they get caught up in the debate over
cultural issues I am telling you tonight
they will be disappointed in the results
in 2024.
and believe me as important as it is to
get to the bottom of the Biden family
corruption I think it's really important
that effort should not overshadow
serious work on the pocketbook issues
that are most important to the voters
Trump is in the lead Now by a lot
because Trump has credibility on the top
concern of Americans in both parties
today
the American dream is dead under Biden
we will have the American dream back
very soon
we will rapidly rebuild the greatest
economy in the history of the world
this is what the voters want more money
in their pockets and jobs that are not
going to be shipped overseas
so here's a novel idea let's give this
message to all of them in all 50 states
in Inner City Philadelphia here in
Minneapolis in Los Angeles and Chicago
no city or state left behind and that's
the angle hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else